[Music]
you
[Music]
hi I'm Rose I'm Senior Account
Specialist at a PR agency I've been in
the industry over 16 years
my focus is technology my name is Danilo
I work for an energy company basically I
can be described as a digital strategist
I'm first-generation American my parents
came here a couple years before I was
born and basically started from scratch
they came to this country to preserve
our heritage for your parents from seed
of mine they came here from Egypt they
were forced being Jewish I guess was not
something that was acceptable my parents
came here started the business and just
always worked hard that's probably where
I learned my work ethic it's do the best
you can
don't give up I had a similar experience
to your parents like I am a first
generation immigrant I was born and
raised the neck with the wire I came
here when I was about 10 my parents
weren't well-off they worked two three
jobs just to pay for our small apartment
that kind of shaped the person that I am
today and you know the work ethic that I
have so it was it was kind of nice that
I was one of the first people in my
family to graduate from college
thanks thanks to their hard work I've
had situations and where I've applied
for a job and you know I've been friends
with the person who's known the hiring
manager and she's gone back to me and
say like oh yeah they love your resume
but they couldn't pronounce your name so
like they sort of like call somebody
else I'm like what that makes no sense I
believe that I recall several interviews
where the conversation was flowing I was
talking about my experience and
successes and then always seems to work
in somehow you know your family oh you
have kids and you do and I try to kind
of steer away from that because you will
get the question and obviously my answer
is I have you know I'm hired to do the
job I'm going to do what I have to do
yeah it's almost like a double standard
I like as a parent I would feel the same
pain as a dad leaving my kids and my
family behind if I had to travel he
would get that question would you I
don't know but I should get that
question it was actually once told well
maybe you shouldn't be working right now
well I don't think that's not someone's
place to say I always did want work I
never wanted to stay home but then again
it's also not an option that's work my
wife has told me you know if my wife is
pregnant and all her co-workers
continually ask her are you gonna come
back to work I guess because a lot of
people want to if they can stay home for
those first year
the child's life after my second son I
did take some time off which I think
hurt my career I've never done this
before
3 2 1 go big difference right yeah
I respect you to make more than that
mean I mean years ago I did make more
than this but again because I took those
couple of years off and only work
part-time it's almost like you have to
start over does this make you feel any
different about yourself a little bit
even though I knew you probably made
more than me it's just actually seeing
it it's tough to actually see I didn't
realize how I would feel
sharing my salary publicly because yes
you're not supposed to but also I feel
like it's a reflection of me but it's
not it's not I love my job and I know
I'm really good at it I feel the same
way like I feel the more you make the
better you are at your job and it
sometimes isn't true why did you agree
to participate in this interview I
agreed to do this interview because I
was kind of curious to find out if they
agree with me and that maybe there's a
minority thing there is are minorities
making less than white American
counterparts in the same level with same
education same career path just because
of some personal experiences that I've
had and that's one of the main reasons I
took this opportunity so just how I may
not think that's an issue I mean see
there's a non-issue you see being a
woman as a non-issue I guess it's not
something you think about because you
don't have to deal with it mhm yeah so
after a full day of exposing secrets are
you happy that you did this I'm happy I
feel like I have like a weight lift off
my shoulders because of such a
controversial topic they you know you're
not supposed to tell your friends or
your family member so it's kind of nice
to be what I'll just talk to someone
if I hadn't known then what I know now I
may have done things differently I may
have better prepared I may have set
myself up better so hindsight is 20/20
but if you have that opportunity to
learn it's a good thing and hopefully
this will help other woman then change
things yeah
[Music]
you